olivier burnotte bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct sur rt france ce matin on va donc
revenir sur les difficultés des
expatriés français à moscou liés aux
tensions diplomatiques elles sont de
quelle nature ces difficultés elles sont
liées à la vie quotidienne c'est à dire
que effectivement suite à cette
politique de durcissement
on peut dire des pays occidentaux à
l'égard de la russie les entreprises
installées en russie d'un trouble et
françaises notamment qui ont un poids
très important
je rappelle que certaines des
entreprises françaises sont parmi les
premiers employeurs de personnel russes
ont des difficultés bien évidemment dès
qu'elles ont des intérêts aux états unis
elle risque des sanctions
extraterritoriale parce qu'elles
viennent travailler en russie
donc évidemment ça a un impact sur les
français les familles qui sont venues
ici qui ont fait le pari de venir vivre
en russie sur le revenu bien sûr tout ça
plus sa crise du coït ce qui fait que
évidemment on est maintenant une
situation assez difficile à la
communauté a perdu pas mal de deux de
ses membres et on est surtout comme on
peut le dire même si c'est un peu
exagéré et pris un otage c'est à dire
que on constate qu'il ya une érosion non
pas naturel mais très très artificielle
de tout ce qui était la politique les
politiques de coopération entre
l'occident et la russie
et c'est évidemment est néfaste pour
tout le monde est-ce que vous qui êtes
expatrié les entreprises françaises
aussi mais tous les expatriés en général
est ce que vous bénéficiez du soutien de
paris aujourd'hui je dirais que le
soutien quand même
été à géométrie variable il est
maintenant en situation minimale à cause
du coc vide mais surtout le problème
c'est que on sent qu'il ya plus de
volonté de coopérer je rappelle qu'il ya
plus d'un an le président macron avait
dit que il y avait des forces
il parlait de l'état profond qui
s'opposaient en france ou au quai
d'orsay à une normalisation avec la
russie une normalisation qui est dans
l'intérêt de tous et on s'aperçoit avec
le temps que malheureusement ça va ça ne
fait qu'évoluer dans un mauvais sens on
espérait des gestes récemment il était
prévu que le les restes du général
napoléonien gudin soient rapatriés en
france ça n'a pas lieu
on attendait visite de président en
macro russie qui n'ont pas lieu
bref on voit que la france est
prisonnière d'autres intérêts en fait on
entend votre sentiment d'isolement est
ce qu'il a été accentuée avec la crise
sanitaire
oui bien sûr les français ici ont très
mal vécu comme d'autres français de par
le monde que en france on se permette de
leur interdire de rentrer en france ce
qui était évidemment
anticonstitutionnelle il a fallu que le
conseil d'état viennent sanctionner le
gouvernement pour une fois je dirais
c'est quand même très surprenant que le
gouvernement ne naît pas accru
raisonnable d'écouter ses juristes donc
maintenant surtout dans une situation où
effectivement il ya un peu de
normalisation mais il ya quand même des
situations difficiles notre consulat
essaie d'aider les familles mais moi je
connais des familles qui sont séparés
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à se rejoindre
il ya des blocages tout ça est lié bien
sûr aux problèmes des vaccins dont on
pourra parler également sur la non
reconnaissance actuelle du vaccin scouts
nique pour ceux qui ont été vaccinés et
bref tout ça ne ne favorise pas une
normalisation dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure et c'est très mal vécu ici
évidemment par les familles françaises
qui vivent dans un pays souverain et
constate quoi à constate que dans les
pays souverains et bien on arrive à
beaucoup mieux géré les soi-disant vague
on arrive à avoir des vaccins
nous sommes la france nous avons inventé
le vaccin mais nous sommes incapables de
produire un vaccin
nous refusons les appels à la
coopération de la russie pour produire
le vaccin scouts nique bref on espère
tous que l' agence européenne va valider
ce vaccin mais rien est acquis surtout
que quand on vient de le voir avec la
biélorussie les prétextes ne manquent
pas pour essayer toujours de recréer
d'attention avec la russie et au fond ça
c'est des éléments extérieurs qui à
chaque fois viennent empêcher la
normalisation faim jusqu'à ce type tel
type d'éléments extérieurs comment est
ce que vous vous comprenez qu'il y ait
d'autres intérêts supérieurs fin'amor à
votre condition de d'expatriés en russie
on constate que cette vieille recherche
tous les prétextes pour pour nuire à
cette relation
je pense aussi d'ailleurs qu' il y a des
forces contraires à cette normalisation
également du côté russe parce que quand
elle voit comment la russie est traitée
en europe où par exemple par la france
qui ne se cachent et perpétuellement
derrière le paravent européen évidemment
ça ne favorise pas les pros
coopération du côté russe donc on est
dans une spirale infernale et pour en
sortir il n'ya qu'une seule solution
c'est que la france retrouve un peu de
souveraineté et soit capable de taper du
poing sur la table et à vis de certains
de ses partenaires européens notamment
pour exprimer une voix qui soit celle de
la neutralité c'est ce que faisait le
général de gaulle c'est le seul ray
xemple com a récemment dans notre
histoire commune où on a pu avoir des
avancées parce que justement la fin la
france a été capable d'avoir une voie
médiane et quelles sont les relations
des expatriés français avec les russes
au quotidien est ce qu on comprends vos
difficultés sur place bien sûr les
russes sont très bien le distinguo entre
ce qui concerne la politique et la vie
au quotidien moi personnellement ça fait
20 ans que je suis en russie et je
constate qu'il n'y a jamais eu de baisse
de l'amour des russes pour la garde des
français qui sont installés ici
il adore notre culture de même qu'on
attend la leur on a beaucoup de points
communs
les entreprises qui viennent s'installer
ici sont rendus succès donc voila et on
a tous les atouts tous les atouts sont
notre côté et on se fait bloquer par des
intérêts extérieurs au nôtre on a eu des
crises en ukraine en géorgie
j'ai pas besoin de les citer toutes et à
chaque fois la france prend toujours des
mauvaises options
il suffit de voir en libye en syrie et
voilà et on se trompe à chaque fois on
se trompe pourquoi pour des intérêts
particuliers visiblement qui ne font
tout pour que ça soit mal entre la
russie et l'occident
c'est déplorable beaucoup de français
ont quitté la russie c
derniers mois on a eu une une perte
sévère effectivement nos effectifs
comme beaucoup de communautés étrangères
il est évident que vous me disiez que je
suis expatrié oui je suis un ancien
expatrié mais tous les français qui sont
ici ne sont pas ne bénéficient pas tous
du statut d'expatrié beaucoup sont
maintenant sur des contrats locaux donc
payer un rouble et donc ils ont beaucoup
de difficultés pour notamment payé par
exemple les frais de scolarité au lycée
français qui sont eux en euros dont vous
voyez la vie quotidienne et parfois très
très compliqué à cause de ces
fluctuations
mais sinon on la vit la vie des gens qui
est ici djoudi n'a pas de soucis on n'a
aucun problème avec les russes et ils
sont si haut si on avait des soucis en
serait pas là
merci beaucoup olivier murlocs d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes responsables
associatifs et candidat aux élections
consulaires en russie